we are born of two universes each of
them in perfect each of limited here
with a cancer organic life from their
ruins a new universe shall be forged in
the fire of the stones it's reality
that's face all life remade in our image
in seal free from the sins of the flesh
we are Ultron Sigma we are your God
stranor Captain America our teams are in
position the enemy's forces are massing
at the palace gates then let's not keep
them waiting
heroes move out I'll lend you my shield
any time with us together this will be a
sync ready fight
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
drunky
chun-li Captain Marvel shall we know
when to quit do you ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
you ready for round three different
streets same fight
you
[Music]
dr. strange heroes of both dimensions
welcome to ours the Prince of Asgard has
come home go show me what we've made on
you
Sir Arthur not bad for one so small and
you Thor are indeed mighty for a heathen
God what's this
fresh fodder no still your lunch my
people what has become of them Thor no
need a panic big guy they're just taking
a nap
they'll be fine eventually stark Spencer
nice weapon Lance a little compensating
for something
only your foolishness Iron Man haha I
like him
ready fight
yeah
Oh
yeah
[Applause]
yes
seven six nine six come on Hawkeye man
this is getting embarrassing let's call
it a tie
yo Dante at an ammo can the ladies come
out to play for you rocket anything be
good evany ivory care today
ready
Oh
Wow
impressive
damn these things are like cockroaches
I've cared behind the red field for once
money people even now they fight well
this was my home to Thor Ultron Sigma's
going to pay for what he's done
[Music]
ready
[Applause]
courage my friend I swear I will release
you from Ultron Sigma's grasp or die
trying
[Music]
where's dr. strange captain doctor can
you get us in the convergence is left to
Asgard's magic weakened we can breach
the prison's walls from here good
commander Redfield Chris you ready huh
I'll take that as a yes this prisoner
better have the answers we need he will
he has to or this is the end
doctor do you feel it this psychic
maelstrom of torment and despair yeah
sucks every prison is the same yeah
then a lot a hard time no but I've put a
lot of Punk's like you away
we can't let them sound the alarm
take them down how much of a secret
mission ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that do it yes
this is it
oh no no bad idea
rocket what is it
seriously you know who this is right doc
back me up here commander we've got a
job to do
we're not leaving without him we can't
hold these guys off forever that field
knows what he's doing
there's small team a didn't they'll get
the job done cap this is Hawkeye we're
out of time
he's coming you see Ultron Sigma I've
got a clear shot take it
all teams engage go-go-go
[Music]
[Music]
hey feel
you still dare challenge us Prince of
Asgard you shall pay for what you've
done to my people Spencer with me I
shall remove you from that throne
villain Oh our will is lost we will
destroy you ready
[Music]
Bert
[Applause]
[Music]
oh do you see now how powerless you
truly are
now for your people Thor they achieved
perfection and soon you shall be their
priests once more
commander Renfield did you have
something to add some grace in sight
you're going down Ultron Sigma that's it
sound banal cliche is fitting that those
would be your final words
get us out of here with pleasure captain
hahaha good
you